what do you do when you're broke in what
do I do when I'm broken when I'm broken
I relish it that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna use it because if I'm broken then
I just found my limitations and until I
know what my limitations are how can i
push them how can I get better but once
once I see it once I feel it once I see
where I was broken then I can attack
that weakness I can fill in that gap I
can reinforce that breach if you break
it means it's time to fortify your will
to make it stronger then look there's
there's all kinds of different ways to
break you can break physically you can
break mentally you can break your heart
you can break your spirit and none of
those are fun and all of those are gonna
leave a mark
but the mark that they leave can be the
mark of victory or it can be the mark of
defeat because every time you break in
in every way that you break while it's a
chance it's definitely a chance for you
to give up and for you to just to fall
apart but there's also opportunity
there's opportunity to get stronger and
get smarter and get faster and get
tougher and get more stable and get more
resilient and get better when you break
them you have the opportunity to show
the world the whole world what you are
really made of so so if you break if if
you break the fight isn't over in fact
if you break the fight is just beginning
and as you crawl up and out of that
dismal and wretched place covered and
you're covered in blood and sweat and
dirt and filth as you rise above what
you were and as you take the form of of
who you are supposed to be
you will see that in the very act of
standing up in the very act of fighting
on you will become and you will remain
unbroken